I always knew I wanted to be a teacher
I think it was my own love of learning
that made me passionate about teaching
Here is a fun fact about me
many years ago I was a student of the British Council
and now I am a teacher
Things I love about teaching at the British Council
is that everybody here is super qualified
and know what they are talking about
it is a fantastic opportunity to assure
qualities and talents with other people
and also learn many different things
Most of all I love it because
I love to see our students improve and develop
and hear from them or from their parents
how learning with us has made a real difference to their lives
What I love about teaching English at the British Council
is the positive and supportive atmosphere
and of course the number of opportunities it provides
Best thing for me as a teacher
is they have really good materials
and also they have very supportive
and positive staff which helps a lot
Being a teacher is a huge responsibility
we shape students future and teach them lifeskills
I teach and write.
Try to inspire my students with the love of language
with the wonder of life, the universe and everything
I wanna say thanks to all the students I've come across over the years
for making my job interesting, rewarding
and something for which I can live
if you want to discover a world of possibilities
Learn with us
There is no better place to learn English
than the British Council